ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata
visto il successo in passato della posta
del cuore ho pensato di riadattare
questo tema e di ampliarlo in un certo
senso cercando di renderlo universale
per la prima volta su questo canale
lanciamo la posta di sonia ho pensato di
invitare un ospite che meglio di
chiunque altro potrebbe portare avanti
questo messaggio e potrebbe veramente in
un certo senso che ricalcare quelli che
sono i passi che stiamo cercando di
seguire ossia sonia stessa grazie eccomi
convenute grazie di cuore per aver
accettato queste non sia poi per le
invita vi faccio solamente un cappello
introduttivo se siete laziali avete mai
messo piede nel lazio da bambini sapete
esattamente chi sono
di chi stiamo parlando estate fund
orlando come me se non lo sapete
sappiate che tutti quanti i cartoni che
avete visto tutti quanti programmi per
bambini che avete visto sono nati grazie
a lei è partito tutto da lei cioè ken il
guerriero lei alla tu sei stata secondo
me la mamma l'amica la baby sitter la
zia di tantissimi bambini ma oggi
arrivano gli adulti una pro mondo
vediamo un pochino che cosa ci chiede
ci può stare
allora eccoci qui ma la malattia la
scelta che ho deciso di intraprendere o
meno fai una mia prima volta con un
idolo ad aldo nasconde fatica mente nel
cesto e che ora ho 21 anni non ho mai
avuto né ho cacciato per un amico
architetto vincente o solo tenuto la
mano a legarsi poi i furti come lo
vorrei aspettare il più questa magica
mia volta che vi giovanna come solo chi
era né un deciso di ragazzi
va bene come stare lontano fino a che
non ho spesi anche più bello possibile
se la scienza
ok aspetta che continua scusa che sto
volando in questo momento voglio
sentirti preparati e non lo so perché un
anno santisti conomici una cosa da stata
squallida che la cosa che non ho mai
detto a nessuno e volevo sponde di un po
mi sembrava la gente quando giudicherà
il velo pensato la spieghiamo una cosa
del genere cioè il catalogo perché
sicuramente ce le ha fatto uno studio
sono anche un po costosi cioè ha fatto
capire sembra quasi che deve dimettere
cartellino su una cosa che invece voglio
dire nasce proprio dal cuore dei
sentimenti non lo so è certo se lo
sceglie nel senso che alto biondo moro
chi azzurri da un altro pianeta
no no è una bella bottiglia di prosecco
piuttosto che pensare a perché non
riesce a farlo con qualcuno non avere
con qualcuno la prima volta chiede di
piuttosto perché non riesci a
innamorarmi na esatto di qualcuno non
riesce a trovare qualcuno che ti piace
porterà nel momento giusto ancora una
arrivata la persona giusta siamo davanti
su questo pianeta sicuramente prima o
poi succede dopo che con miguel hai
capito passato questa notte o con pablo
il giorno dopo quella che ne è cambiato
niente
come quando ti dicono dopo i 18 anni su
tre fontane è tutto uguale
anna già del gigolo avventura grazie
grazie grazie per la fiducia
i tuoi segreti muoiono con noi certo
quella responsabilità anche tutte le
risposte ma è facile ma che non hai
capito perché
io sono a posto sono bravo come birillo
bravissimo una bella spallata nella vita
si capisce quello che si farà in futuro
quello che si vuole diventare da grande
come si capisce quando lo si capisce
grazie ciao io è una domanda che faccio
sempre ragazzi che cosa vuoi fare da
grande l'astronauta le teorie letto uno
mi ha detto il papa un altro mi ha detto
il contadino dottore infermiere però
quando si è piccoli non si hanno queste
idee così ben precise poi
inevitabilmente crescendo perché è
inevitabile che ti scontri gole di
fiducia no e quindi tutto va
ridimensionato in questo senso proprio
di non sapere cosa fare da grandi se ci
pensi però è anche tanto dovuto
all'epoca in cui viviamo nell'incertezza
la materia ma anche una che siamo il
paralmento ragazzo che ha per il
telefono vede in sta che non vede
facebook dove tutti quanti cercano di
vendere la versione migliore di se
stessi dove vanno avanti in quest'epoca
dove se tu non sfondi già da quando i 15
anni immagini di tutte le star di disney
che poi fanno queste carriere a quel
punto non male di non fare più niente
quello diventa lo specchio di quello che
dovrebbe anche la nostra un'età nella
quale ho il bianco e nero
c'è quindi se tu fai un lavoretto di
colpo sembra che per sempre ti rassegni
rai e la vita è finita
buttatevi a fare qualcosa perché almeno
incominciare da capire cosa non vuole
preparare insegnate ordine alla maestra
ho cambiato ho fatto la segretaria
presso un commercialista capivo niente
di numerica dei disastri però insomma
l'ho fatto ha la prova che ho fatto
supertreno scrivere a macchina tutti
venivo già perché se ero io che non so
quanti errori avevo fatto però
continuava continuò a scrivere e quindi
tuttavia come segretaria poi da cosa è
nata cosa insomma c'è stata un
cambiamento diverso però penso che
insomma uno delle anche crederci un
pochino noi magari anche un lavoro
semplice però ti porta ad altre strade
anche quando fai un lavoro che ti piace
tantissimo non vivi di sola passione
comunque arriverà quel giorno quella
giornata no quelle cose che dovrei fare
per cui in realtà tv rimboccare
anche se devi comunque fare l'adulto
applicarti che saggio insieme sono un
mix un nuovo android è visto come sono
migliorati giusto per farvi ridere
che schifo perché voglio questo
bellissimo ritratto di gas al tg1 perché
è scritto ancora sia persona che è
interessante
poche ore dopo
ok non serve più ci siamo lasciati
grazie lo stesso se minore le scrivo
cuore i quali cuore mi dispiace mi
risponde ci siamo rimessi insieme ma mi
vergognavo della mia instabilità emotiva
[Risate]
sul pezzo insomma ragazza su un pezzo ho
appena letto il tuo post dopo dove parli
dell'ipotetica pasta di cui nessuno
molto a favore perché credo che tanti
abbiamo visto naturalmente io ho detto
posta di cuper che doveva nascondere non
ti voglio detronizzare suona libraio di
un consiglio contrario di quello che
dici sei molto saggio e ispiri fiducia
alle persone ho 26 anni da un anno
bellissimo anche se è difficile ho messo
alla luce una bambina che ho chiamato
isabel emessa da sola perché suo padre
ci abbandonate quando io ero al quarto
mese di gravidanza
ho tanta rabbia e tanto ri contro di lui
murray soltanto a sputargli in faccia
non vorrei fare altro ha cercato tutti
pretesti le scuse per lasciarmi alla
fine ho fatto una cosa più drastica
ovvero tradirmi e poi andarsene
il consiglio che ti chiedo è se lui
dovesse tornare e pretendere di vedere
sua figlia che oggi porta il mio cognome
che cosa dovrei fare
l'istinto mi dice caccia traversa ii
addosso tutta la rabbia che ti ha fatto
però per mia figlia non devo essere
egoista questa rete stessa
se ne volesse conoscere su linea fissa
la pretesa di tenerla adesso magari
quando tra vent arie e chi lo sa non so
cosa devo fare
mantova presupposto grazie perché il
pensiero che tu possa veramente pensare
che noi siamo veramente degni di
ascoltare secondo me una cosa così a me
veramente riempie di giorni fa veramente
molto piacere ti ringrazio mi ha molto
toccato anche si sente da quanto si
sente onorata si sente tutto
non credo che avrà del bisogno forse di
leggere la bambina ha sicuramente
crescendo sua figlia si è allora lì e il
confronto è duro perché vai a
giustificarsi di fronte a un
comportamento del genere tanto comunque
i figli ti vengono a cercare no però lei
insomma brava ti stai facendo tanti
problemi di quello che potrà succedere
in futuro di quello che potrà capitare
cioè io ti invito veramente a cercare di
affrontare dentro di te tutta questa
rabbia questa tristezza e soprattutto di
trovare un nuovo equilibrio e non
smettere di guardarsi intorno e non
pensare che una brutta persona
automaticamente sia uno stampino
pertanto per brutto i miei al suo a meno
certa qual è la difficoltà
sì ma come le pays come vi viene air
ancora se sta bene a casa è come se la
difficoltà a crescere ma è la vita c'è
anche questo cioè i figli vanno amati
cresciuti non è soltanto il fatto di
metterli al mondo nola favore della
paternità che sa cosa uno possa
immaginare mentre realtà me c'è un mondo
fantastico da scoprire
perdonami pure la frase di hai
conosciuto
cioè nel senso purtroppo ci sta e con un
codardo un immaturo infantile ti auguro
di trovare veramente una persona vicino
a te che possa amarti amare tua figlia
se fosse la propria come se fosse la
propria ma soprattutto come merita
non credo che un essere così possa in
questo momento farlo chi può sapere se
un giorno nera col capo cosparso di
cenere come si dice fatti suoi
sicuramente la ragazza grazie ma quando
uno soffre per amore uno vorrebbe dirti
guardo mani passa tutto magari fosse
così vero ci vuole il tempo purtroppo ha
un dolore che deve piano piano andare
via scemando quindi importante non
chiudersi non stare da soli ma che
magari circondarsi dalle persone che ci
fanno star bene perché no anche da
labrador mar da anche da netflix fino a
che conta tormenti esatto quindi bisogna
andare avanti insomma il dolore piano
piano si lavora su te stesso prendi
questo momento in cui non ti piace per
fare cose al fine di pià certi che sia
la palestra che sia mangiare bene che
sia interessarti di qualcosa che sia
dare amore che ho amici per riceverne
esatto è un grandissimo problema nelle
relazioni con i miei amici non riesco a
mantenere un amicizia per più di 12 anni
e succede sempre perché a un certo punto
vengo ignorata comincia a diventare
egemone fanalino di coda del gruppo
quella chiesa anche manca non è un
problema anzi non capisco si sono
l'unica cattiva o meno anche perché non
mi sembra di esserlo da tutti ne
propongo si ripete ascoltare dai
consigli se non sempre quella si cerca
di capire come gli altri e pare una mano
lei ascolta tutti domande che ascoltate
e se stavate venuta questa idea di fare
il contrario quello che si incomincia a
in genere inizia a essere più attenta
senza vedere quanto quelle persone sono
disposte a comportarsi come tutti i
comparti con loro e quindi non rimanerci
per ma le mani un in sicurezza in
comincia a filtrare perché non tutti
sono abituati alla gentilezza e non
tutti forse la meritano o la cerca di
quanti anni hai veramente tutti lo so se
con android te l'ho detto sono brillano
i robot non hanno un'età sentirlo della
materia che insegna è veramente un onore
e mera molto più facile dare
consigliando indetto da otto anni è che
la presenza è difficile il meglio di me
ma io direttamente ai genitori esatto
non ero mai e da una parte del piccolo
perché era troppo semplice però qui è
diverso per cui giornata 6 dan dovette
consiglia persone fatte finalmente coi
figli e mi stai dicendo che questo è
difficile sarei felice di in maniera
diversa si propone per questa è un'area
io direi un secondo prenderci una pausa
perché sono a pezzi
stiamo veramente morendo e anche in
quanto auto ma devo andare a ricaricare
le batteria è un'altra piccola urgenza
si ok perfetto per una pausa lunga la
settimana ci vediamo quindi il prossimo
giovedì sempre alle 14 con un altro
video insieme a sony alla seconda parte
ok ciao ciao